hi guys welcome to the special edition
of adopt
nicola with one and only grandmaster
sergey karjakin uh thank you for being
here
it's a great honor to be here with
grandmaster karjakin
and also for
with the international master eric rosen
who is actually one of the people
responsible for me to coming to
twitch and to wfm maria meganova
fotochess
who is actually largely responsible for
arranging this match
thank you guys thank you nicolas it's a
pleasure
great to be here hi eric
[Music]
hello sergey thank you uh you know i
i want to say a couple of things before
we pledge into the match
uh you know there is a very small club
of people who play the match for world
championship
since 2010 for the past 10 years that
club is
probably the most exclusive club of all
chess players it's basically
onion topalov girlfriend
then magnus won the championship in 2013
sergey played for world championship
2016
and fabiano caruana have played in 2018
that's a grand total of six people
that played this it's as
exclusive club in chess world as you can
have
and the the biography the curriculum
vita of
to my today's opponent is absolutely
fascinating
he was an international master at 11 he
was a grandmaster at
12. he was a rapid world champion in
2012 he was a blitz world champion in
2016.
uh you know i'm basically in awe and
honored to be
in the same virtual chess board virtual
room
with sergey kayaking so welcome sergey
kayak sergey
i i'm hoping to we will be able to see
you more on twitch and this is actually
one of the ideas behind this
match yes maybe it will be my first step
very good very good and open field media
for the record is
you know shout out to the sponsor for
the match open film media is sponsoring
this match
and open film media has basically is
more than
happily sponsor any match that
grandmaster
karjakin wants to play in the future and
we're actually going to work on it
later and with with maria also a huge
shout out
to international master eric rosen who
doesn't need any introduction
he is twitch royalty he has
his youtube channel basically uncovered
for me
in back in 2018 the how
much chess has advanced in the last
last couple of years in the last three
or four years with the advent of twitch
and youtube and online playing
so thank you eric for agreeing to
commentate this match
oh it's really a pleasure yeah i i
didn't know that
uh i was one of the people who inspired
you to to get into twitch
so absolutely yeah yeah and
also by the way uh eric congratulations
on 200
000 youtube subscribers that you that
you hit
oh thanks so much yeah no it's it's been
exploding recently
have to have to probably thank the
queen's gambit film for uh
making chess so popular yes
congratulations i appreciate it very
impressive
thank you all right so uh
without much to do you guys uh
just to summarize the adoption format
it's 10 games
one one attempted adoption
basically if i draw one game i win the
match
which very frankly according to the ill
of this the difference
here is uh i have four percent chances
but i'll give it a puncher's choice i
use chuck webner
who once knocked down muhammad ali as my
as my role model and we will see what
happened
at any rate it doesn't matter it's very
great and a great honor to have
sergey koryakin on in my channel here
and
i have already i already feel like
that's a huge victory
okay so uh the way this works
is you guys should be able to hear
commentary by
eric and maria i am going to disconnect
i'm going to take my headphones off so i
won't hear the commentary and i already
see a challenge
from sergey and i think we are basically
ready to play
all right guys time to start wish me
luck i'll
i will i will accept the challenge now
good luck
good luck good luck
okay so they can't hear us correct i
hope so i hope not
okay not that we can really help sergey
here but uh
of course we don't want to to to have
any reason for anyone to suspect that we
were biased against him right
not at all okay so i see the the first
game
is underway looks like uh looks like a
bishop's opening from from sergey
actually didn't get the chance to ask
nicola how much he prepared for this
um without asking him i can tell you
that
nikola is always thoroughly prepared
and it's it's really impressive how much
obviously he's a busy uh businessman
and has a family and supports all of us
on twitch
uh watches
watches uh the streams all the time so
at the same time
he always finds time to prepare for the
match and this match
was planned only six six days ago and he
also had an adoption match on sunday
against laurenc and he managed to avoid
that adoption by winning the game
five if i'm not mistaken um
and then also prepared for this one
so
that's i guess a good start for him but
uh
yeah i i don't know if i'd be able to
avoid adoption against uh against
karjakin
um do you think you can adopt nicola
well nicola has been me a few times just
in uh in like kind of friendly but
competitive games on stream
um so i don't know i would have to take
it very seriously to
to be able to adopt him um now he's
definitely uh
definitely a like good knowledgeable
player but it'll be interesting to see
how like sergey uh deals with him
um and so far i've liked the opening
choice from white
just kind of uh a nice stable sort of
vienna
oh what we call this like vienna gambit
type thing but not really a gambit
um a lot of potential for white to
attack on the king's side
in the middle game
so do you think sergey will
castle alongside and then go like g4 g5
it's possible um i mean white uh
white usually has a hard time castling
kingside in this position right because
this bishop
uh controlling g1 um i've seen cases
where white just leaves a king in the
center
and then the storms um
the bishop before i don't um not
entirely sure about
uh the bishop was just so nice on uh
[Music]
but of course knight a4 is always
possible to
to to try to trade it unless black will
play something like
a6 and hide it on a7 yeah that's a very
typical idea
yeah yeah it's such a good bishop on
this diagonal
but you know what uh sergey is allowing
here is bishop takes c3 and then
just kind of casually walking into
having triple pawns
yeah but also immediately h6 and g5
is coming and sergey will have to take
one f6
because otherwise he's dropping only
four
um h6 g5 there there is on poisson
i've taken g6 yes but maybe it's still a
position
yeah but you you will leave the e4 pawn
uh completely alone
so i like queen d3 because it reinforces
e4
reinforces c3
but there he could have taken on c3
again which probably already becomes
dangerous since
uh nikola decided to castle long side
because you don't want to
expose b file against
the world relates champion
yeah you have to be careful i i do like
the way nicola is playing like he hasn't
um
he's simply cracked he's playing solidly
uh he's he is spending more time
um i like his expression here
i don't think we've seen beth harmon do
that uh that pose like
both arms over the head but no no
you also said that he's wearing his
luckiest hat
uh yeah nicola has a lot of hats and
we've seen him
changing hats during the same adoption
match
are you a hat person do you wear hats
like an over-the-board chest
no no no i don't either i feel like
well i feel like no hat has
the size like comfortable enough for my
head
so i just feel very uncomfortable
wearing it unless i need it
to to be warm which obviously
it has to serve a practical use yeah and
then
you have a lot of a lot of practical use
like that
but yeah it just feels a bit weird and
you cannot really see
around you but on the other hand i can
understand
over the board you don't want to like uh
see
much stuff going on around you maybe it
helps you focus
it does limit your field of vision maybe
sometimes prevents you from
looking at your opponent which could be
useful
um but that doesn't apply to online chat
you need some other type of hat or
rather face uh covering but
that's another story maybe we will have
some new fashion next year
for the board chess anyway it looks like
it's going to be kind of a long grind
like equal material eight pawns for each
side
each side has their own file g
if not for knight e5 rook g3 would be a
nice move
yeah but rook g7 probably was uh safer
in this position it's just that the
queen is a bit
unlucky not not very
well-placed yeah very unfortunate square
for the queen on d7
but he now is takes on c4 knight of six
so he's desperadoing the rock but he's
gonna be down
material and the end of this yeah maybe
taking on c4 was
uh better that's the thing when you play
like a very very strong grand master all
it takes is like
one tactical oversight to just get a
losing position
but up until rook g3 like nicole is
doing very well
but maybe he just did not realize that
he can take on c4
sometimes touch moves can be like an
oversight
like a blind spot
yeah rook takes c4 would have definitely
offered some better chances
of course then by taking on f6 sergey
would have
protected e4 and you still need to be
careful with your rook
not to get it trapped
if we look at the current position like
this move c5 is actually it's like it's
a nice way of making progress for whites
because usually when you're up the
exchange the way you end up
making progress is by opening files for
the rooks
and of course after bc5 he can take on
c5 so it's not even
not even a sacrifice of a pawn although
he could have sacrificed as well to
activate uh his rooks
and now of course g6 is very weird d6 is
very weak
i mean there's knight c4 but after rook
d4
it's not gonna last for uh for black
yeah and rook c8 he simply will move the
king away
and b3 is coming
yeah king b1 is it's a type of move you
usually see in the middle game to
protect the king
but it's still relevant here and now b3
should be pretty much lights out for
black
yeah these rooks are monsters
we're gonna have to remind maybe both
players to mute their mics
maybe between games
anyway um do
are the players rejoining the call for a
quick analysis
yeah yes just a very brief uh well
that's what happens when you
play a first game against the super gm
you end up missing simple tactics but
that's fine
and i have to say one thing yes that's
why that's why i played rogue one
to be ready yeah no it's fine
uh oh thank you laura just a huge shout
out to laura owner
who is now putting spam this standard to
make sergey blunder
lauren is the wgm from slovenia that
they played actually the same
similar match against uh uh yesterday so
all right um i don't know if
eric what we just had one kind of
general question for you nicola
um how much specific preparation did you
do
for for sergey did you scout out his
openings or
i did but i didn't did i did didn't have
this on my list i checked all his
chest-based stuff
and this wasn't part of the prep which
is unfortunately rather obvious
so and what about you play this opening
quite well
no it was fine i i just i assume that i
can take advantage of the g
file but then it turned out and i
assumed that there will be a c5 coming
i just didn't expect the night sacrifice
so well i i think that that also you
should have taken on c3 when you when
you have a chance
to force me to take with a pawn and yes
yeah that would be in before you play
queen d3 right yeah that would have
i was very thank you sergey know i was i
was worried
that then i was planning on castling
along
and that would have tripled the pawns i
was worried that that would be opening
the b
file but we'll even learn that's that's
why these matches are being played and
this is why
you know it's uh uh you know playing
like this is there and thank you sergey
again for
for doing this this was a very
educational loss
um as most people who follow my channel
know i have
i have a stream every monday night
monday at 8 00 pm eastern that's
called my best losses so i'll actually
show this game this was very instructive
okay uh we are ready to go i'm gonna
mute myself
and one request uh sergey if you can
mute your microphone too
that would be good
nice child there you can uh sergey you
can do
in zoom actually pretty easily um i
after the next game okay awesome okay
so that was game one
i mean if nick nicola can like avoid
tactical blunders um hopefully he can
can put up some some bigger fights
this game he has white
yeah so let's see if if sergey will walk
into a prep
mm-hmm we're gonna see a mainline night
or
[Music]
night earth is one of those openings
that just scares me
like completely like just there's so
much theory
but to be a world-class grand master you
have to really have to know what you're
doing
yeah but i mean against sergey
i probably will be terrified in any
opening
that's true yeah no but but kudos to
nicola for uh
for going into maybe some sharp theory
he's playing actually trendy lines h3 g4
idea yeah yeah he likes to play adam's
attack
we'll see yeah this is out of my
wheelhouse of like
offbeat openings or tricky gambits but
i mean generally the idea for white is
to like develop
um i get some nice piece harmony like
bishop e3 and then later
pawn swarm on the king side like f4
g5 the short castle i
think white he normally either delays
the castling
or castles long side and plays g5 pretty
pretty soon well in this position it
looks like white's losing a pawn
as after this last move before white has
to move away the knights
yeah maybe instead of wow look at this
move knight t5
okay so now
if it takes getting into some
trouble bishop e7 this is very
cold-blooded
g5 and where does the knight go that's
the problem if the
y if the pawn takes on d5
the knight will have to retreat to d7
right well there's g5
not immediately i mean right we first
take and now of course
and now g5 and i think black needs to
give up
the piece back this must be
prep
i mean nicholas still playing slower
than than sergey
um yeah that's that's of course one of
these but you you have to play very
actively here if you play like
just a a slow move and blacks can cast
g5 as well you have to do it right so g5
there's knight takes d5
but then maybe knight f5 like things get
very messy very quickly
another five of course is one of the
main ideas after g5
knight c6 wow i guess that's another
idea
yeah one question you have the engine
evaluation turned on yes but i in this
position i will not trust it
okay because i have the bar but i don't
have any lines g5
now and the knight has nowhere to go and
probably the only move is castle
there's also knight g8 but that's kind
of a depressing wow he goes for
it but what do you do after queen g4 g4
the rook is hanging the the pawn is
hanging is
is is nikola gonna win it it's not it's
difficult to find this is the only move
that that that is right there in front
of you queen d4
does he see it but he's just double
checking i hope so
he still has three minutes so it's quite
a lot of time for such a position
i mean you you need to have the board
vision like just spot the two things
that are undefended
and find the one move to attack both of
them and that just wins a rook
right yeah one of the rooks yeah
oh my god oh he doesn't find it
it's tough it's it's tough when you're
playing a super gm because you don't
expect them so
you just did not expect yeah he trusted
him
yeah too much so now
or sergey of course saw this and he will
move the
or the king but it's it's still not easy
for black to fight
he can also play bishop v3 now and then
i do like king fa because it
it got out of the pin and it defends g7
but bishop e3 what does black do
um c7 there's bishop b6
it looks like bishop e3 just traps the
rook actually yeah yeah
and if rook a there's c7 so it's at
least an exchange of course taking on g7
would have been so nice
such a position against the gm
yeah no if he found that move it
probably would have been just easily
winning
um that's something he really needs to
maintain his time as well
oh definitely yeah because an exchange
up
is quite nice and of course the king is
uh without the castle and the rook is
still on h8 but sergey will be blitzing
the most
and that's the thing like even if you
have like a good position
you still need enough time to be able to
convert
so now he plays queen d4 unfortunately i
moved too late no it's not
not the same
[Music]
still needs a lot of uh
work from sergey because he is nice
very underdeveloped yeah they're still
in the in their starting positions
and they're all corn in shade but of
course it's not the time to take the
pawns
especially that he's allowing d5 at
least
even knight c6 and and the the c pawn
very quickly turned from the stream to a
league
a4 and he can take on a6 and it will be
very hard to stop the pawns on the
queen's side
i think that's probably what you have to
play for he basically has a
rook and a knight down and this
phone race probably will be faster than
sergey's development
but it's still double-edged yeah i mean
it takes it takes some time for black to
um
to develop knight e5 is a nice move just
very solid center square unleashing the
rook too probably threatening roxy too
i have a feeling time is going to tell
the story here yeah
maybe bishop before attacking the
[Music]
the knight well corresponds here
don't really matter that much once i do
like bishop f4 because
you're just trying to to use the pieces
that you have that are developed also
it's kind of a skewer here
especially after rook rook 81 coming let
me skewer pins
97 man this uh
this game i i see the engine bar just
fluctuating so much
it's already been a roller coaster it
doesn't understand much here
it's a true sharp position
you can probably snag the pawn but maybe
not
a queen b4 okay going after d6
d6 is a more important pawn
and we should note that g5 has been
loose for many moves but
black can't really take it without
worrying about d6
yeah d6 is more important here that's
why maybe 95
again is a forced move but 95 there's
going to be rookie d1
and white's building a pressure with all
the pieces you can also try to trade the
queens by queen b8
rook d1 natural move h6 maybe
is there rook takes e7 here just um i
mean it's a tactical idea eight
he also has the check on b8 right oh he
plays it wow
so now it's a rook it's a full rook but
it's dollar rook but it's almost a
wooden shield
i think i think group d6 was stronger
oh yeah rook g6 would attack the queen
the problem here in some cases uh
white's pinned along the d-file
yeah yeah it's it is actually a pin
he is not threatening anything except
for taking on e7 but then queen
recaptures
yeah the i don't i don't even know what
the threat is maybe some like rook d2
move just got out of the pin
but still like very complex like black
has some problems to solve
in king h2 did he have g6
instead of king h2 g6 would have been
insane
yeah i mean it's it's just threatens
queen f4 and mate
wow so he's he's giving away his rook he
was giving away
he's gonna win e7 but
he'll be down exchange from g8
and amazingly the rook on h8 got into
the game without needing to move
that's why also was better to
yeah keep the file closed but he's
already a very long time
oh my god what the game this is much
different than the first game like first
game was solid then one tactical issue
but this game like just a complete mess
rookie one and it's probably over
sergey can take a sweet time
he's probably very relieved
that's a wake-up call yeah
oh something so there's even oh so there
is one trick if rook h3
looks like a free pawn there's queen c8
but no way no way sergey is going to
fall into that
yeah if we remove the rogue from h8 it's
uh
then it would be nice what a game no
definitely have some questions for the
players
i i think i was lost a few times
this is your game from 2008 sergey right
this whole knight to d5
you played this in 2008 you you mean
against luke
luke one really right yes luke manuel
this this is how the whole adam's attack
thing started with knight d5 right
that's the game
you know so good my games i i actually
forgot my game i was just
just playing i knew that this after 95
that white is uh
supposed to be better but going there to
winning is
obviously difficult yeah yes but i i
think the the key moment was on move 15
that you didn't play queen d4 which was
winning
yes and this is one of those unfortunate
moments
when you see right after you make a move
queen d4 here was winning yes
yeah yes and also i think that on move
22
i i mean i i was very much wrong with
the
knight 95 with this 97 this was losing
on time uh and then on move 22 you could
have played bishop g6 or rupert d6
rookie what's the point
yes and then if black text takes take
then queen queen beat what's going on
cannot return yeah ah yeah okay
yeah i see that probably bishop d6s
bishop
yeah all right well
that was a fun game to watch yeah that
was definitely
to play creatively but i should have
played more solid much more sorted
okay no thank you uh yeah yeah this is
basically 2008
uh just uh adam's attack started become
which is h3 sicilian against neither
started being popular against sergey's
game against luke 1
villi in 2008 and of course
you know i knew this game but it's very
hard to
remember the game with five plus two and
adrenaline rushing in the whole nine
yards so hey anna maya thank you
thank you for the raid that's very
greatly appreciated thank you i'm sorry
eric we
i i interrupted you you wanted to ask
ask us some questions oh no you you
didn't interrupt um i i was just
impressed that you
you knew this line better than uh than
sergei
i wouldn't say that but that's fine okay
all right well guys this is definitely
going on my best losses how nicola
almost won a game against the super
grandmaster
all right this honestly this is already
this match is already worth it
i'm gonna brag about it for the rest of
my life
thank you sergey let's let's play let's
play next game
all right yeah that was very very
nerve-wracking
this is crazy so we should note that
even if
nicola manages to draw or win a game
they'll still play the full 10 games
correct
yeah do not vote for sergey just for the
sake of all the 10 games
we are not going to be taken taken off
of our
uh entertainment anyway
okay so different opening mainline
spanish
nice to see like every game uh they're
mixing things up
so far a4
a4 is considered like one of these
anti-martial variations
where now it's more difficult for black
to get a true martial
gambit
okay i wonder if uh
this is also some kind of a prep
i mean nicola playing quickly and and d5
looks to be
maybe some version of a marshall like
it's a pawn sacrifice because after
knight takes g5 e5 is hanging yeah
white also sometimes plays c3 not d3
i wonder if there is any difference here
because i saw marshall
marshall in this uh
c3 oh yeah with the pawn on d3 maybe
it's a bit different
yeah because the pawn is still hanging
but what do i do you do now
about 92 okay very solid move
[Music]
maybe
you can bring the knight back and open
the diagonal for the bishop
or maybe queen d7 with the idea to bring
the rook
i'm just curious like um if you don't
defend the pawn like if you play a move
like queen d7
wow knight t4 the d4 is a cool idea
actually no going back
so he's doubling down on giving away the
pawn
but this move it it does a few things it
pressures the bishop on b3
it does help unleash this bishop on b7
also potentially he can play c5
you see five ideas yeah and one of the
one of the main forms of compensation
for black in this line
is a slight squared bishop and directed
at the king's side
because white's own light squared bishop
it doesn't really
serve great defense of the squares on
the king side it's a bit out of play on
b3
and sergey and sergey looks to be maybe
out prepared yet again
uh-oh the times were flashing for me i
think there is a bit of server lag
it should be okay now
i think it was fine here but maybe
that was only very brief yeah so
for those of you guys who don't know and
uh yeah for me also
now happened um so nicolas stewarten
is also streaming you can find him
using the comment nicola in my channel
we have the same command
i have a nikola command too
yeah so please uh open his
stream as well you can open it in the
second tab
or use um
twitch um what was it
called multi twitch
yes malted which you can use it for and
he deserves a follow especially for that
last game
and for this game like look at his
knights wow monsters
oh my god i wonder if it's already
preferable for black
this bishop won't see this bishop on c1
look at that like it's i mean yeah
white's bishops aren't so useful here
and black has some like really nice
piece harmony
g2 is a very clear target
um i do have the engine bar engine
is liking black but it seems it just
seems very complex
like you're down upon and you're gonna
have to play accurately to get
compensation and of course once you are
a bit too slow the
knights will unleash on e4 attacking the
knight on f4 then the bishop will come
to back to life
and then all of the pieces of white
can potentially direct towards the king
of nicola and
this is very double-edged reminds me of
the previous game like you're down
material and you're gonna have to play
actively and accurately to get some edge
yeah okay so he goes ahead and takes a
bishop
that move maybe helps white a bit more
because it um
it does but on the other hand the bishop
player is a bishop player
it's true and maybe he can put the
bishop on f6 after
retreating to maybe knight e6
i don't like knight g6 as much because
it's kind of
out of the play so maybe knight e6
bishop f6
uh some pressure on b2 right
but white has initiative like after
knight takes b3 white's someone making a
threat
yeah yeah that's why i did not i i
you you really want to attack with every
move
have create a threat and have
everything with the temple and now he
allows to
trade a bad bishop for a good night
so maybe this is also a pressure fresh
air breath
of fresh air yeah we might see a two
bishops versus two night situation
which um i mean usually you like having
two bishops against two knights but if
you're down upon
yeah and it's a central bone it might
not be so fun for black
but sergey does take his time to think
meanwhile thank you so much chess
ninja for your ten thousand beats
if you are uh if you if you place this
as a bed
on nicola we have quite a good odds here
look at this move knight a5 like just
leaving
leaving them on f4 going after the
bishop
yeah sergey is counter-attacking uh
yeah taking on f3 maybe is giving up
your
of course bishop player is gone also now
it seems like the compensation has
disappeared yeah and the pawn structure
immediately reveals
all of the weaknesses especially with
knight c6 immediately
coming and you don't really know where
to put the queen now
oh queen h4 and the problem now is
white's pieces are
very well positioned and without the
lights for a bishop like you you would
love a lightweight bishop for uh for
black in this position
but now he was also losing another pawn
he cannot recapture because
and knight and he's walking into it it's
another puzzle rush
combination yeah that's why the queen on
d7 probably was better
although very passive but at least
defending this e7 square
i think now he's realizing his doom yeah
but still he he managed to make sergey
really try to find the best uh
continuation after this bishop on c1
being
completely it is impressive like his
opening preparation he's getting
interesting dynamic positions um
i'd be very curious okay he just resigns
be very curious to see
what he could have done better there
yeah black was fine
but no no i need to take on b3 i think
yeah i i i forgot the line
here that's yeah you you have many
options
actually after knight e5 to f3
a lot of news for you yeah i just uh
i did like it's kind of nerve-wracking
here and i completely overlooked this
simple
the relatively simple tactic i think
knight b3 we needed to play it earlier
oh i actually think that knight f4 is
fine
oh well you could you could take on v3
also
earlier yeah uh
yeah i remembered the game that you
played against the magnus in which you
played knight
that magnus played 96 at some point
and then it was basically an equal end
game but
that's what obviously it wasn't in this
line so
oh it was yeah with
a h3 it was an h3 line and i was hoping
to use that i
i know that night with the knight d4 my
book knowledge basically stopped
unfortunately
okay and sergey what point were you out
of your
kind of opening preparation
uh well i i knew that there is move g5
after
d3 and takes takes knight b2 i think it
was
some games maybe carlson or something
but magnus played f6 as far as i
remember maybe i
i'm wrong but i think he played f6 and
and what would you recommend instead of
knight takes b3
because we were liking black's activity
but wasn't sure how uh how to best
continue
i'm not sure also but but
at least i think that uh even after
knight b3 and b3
it was better to play some knight e6
move
and to keep the bishop on b7 and the
in the night and
actually c5 instead of knight take b3
was also interesting
d5 here or maybe bishop c5 also
put some pressure on f2
bishop c5 yeah
it's not so easy for me to make a move
yeah i'm not sure if i want to take one
d4 because some knight g2 or something
yeah oh yeah the end of this position is
that black needs to play
c5 and then c4 and then put bishop on c5
but the right
continuation basically escaped me i
actually played this
a lot but obviously playing this against
the
somebody my strength and playing this
against sergey is a very different
proposition so okay
all right thank you sergey let's uh
time for the i'm gonna mute myself and
time for
the next game okay good luck
good luck wow
what a prep yeah no it's impressive like
nicola
i didn't realize he's so like
knowledgeable about like these uh
i guess these theoretical games um
definitely way more knowledgeable than
me uh
regarding recent opening theory oh and
now they are in karakon
i wonder if we will see a talbot
variation
what is a tall variation is h4
and h4 and h
i think it's also g4 he sacrifices on b2
if queen plays to b6
g4 g4 now
i demand i demand you for
it's another line i don't know too much
about but i i know there's a lot of
theory
i do this one already in some adoption
matches
uh nicole and nicola did uh they did
beat the
title players with this variation
so he's taking his time here he might be
choosing between g4 immediately and
first maybe
bishop to e3
but i think we he knows what he wants to
play
well maybe he wasn't expecting sergey to
play akira khan i i can't remember
sergey playing too many kyrokans in
like professional events
oh it might be a small curveball the g4
okay
i called it
okay so now i think yeah knight c3 and
if um
he might even play f4 i'm not sure but
maybe
something simple more do you know why
the bishop goes to d7 and not h7 because
it seems so counterintuitive
um it feels like sergey
is now a bit more
cautious knowing because he already
knows it's a tall variation
and yeah so now uh white is is giving up
on b2
and sometimes they even give up their
rook
i'm so excited
oh this looks like really really sharp
because nicola knows this
line so well uh-huh and i'm sure that
sergey is already regretting going for
kara khan
yeah like now it doesn't even look like
a carol khan it just looks like a sad
french black
okay come on f4 f4 do it
is that four like the main is this still
it's one one of the lines
yeah what would you do on the f4
uh maybe knight c6 i mean usually black
wants to apply pressure
i think i think you can play h5 and g5
there i was looking at it but i i think
my head is just
not big enough to remember all that
well you should note now that if queen
digs b2 white always has this rook b1
uh resource with rook takes b7
so nikola very patient with queen d2
but it's it keeps all the threads uh f4
still might be played
uh he is kind of forcing h5 because you
feel nervous about uh the possibility of
white to play h5 and then g5 and you
don't have h5 to close up the position
and of course here the easiest is to
close position for black and turn
all of the play to the queen side which
for black would would be really good
because of all the pieces heading that
direction
but now after g5 i think
so g5 is it's a move that usually you
don't want to play like a very
anti-positional
and the big drawback with this move is
you you give away the f5 square for
black's knight so
sergey is probably dreaming of those
potential knight outposts
the question is what else do you do as
white do you play f3
oh hedgehog thank you for gifting
yourself to am
adam in nicholas channel
a lot of support for nicola guys
you have a lot of nice emotes in the
channel please
spam yeah you use the nikola command
nicola emotes my channels emotes as well
let's let's root for nicola
it's another game like he's getting a
nice lean development
and he hasn't even sacrificed anything
yet
yeah i normally don't like to take on h5
because you
allow activity for the rook at the later
stage
and i always feel nervous once you trade
the queens the rook
on h8 becomes a beast
and your pawn on h4 of course becomes
the target immediately
at the same time white scanning
initiative yeah activeness there's still
a lot of initiative
and he can always play h5 that's he's
defended
g5 cannot be played
the question is like how do you make use
of your leading development
and your space advantages white is it
visually it looks really nice
but like black is super solid
everything's defended
oh you know what i'm sensing another
sacrifice
and it takes d5 yes we already saw
knight takes knight
i guess knight to d5 sacrifice
it wasn't even taking anything and he
did not hesitate
the move was played quite quickly now
he's thinking no he took on c5
okay so very peaceful series of trades
well white still has quite a nice
position both both knights of black are
not developed so many
already the third game out of four
sergey is severely underdeveloped not
following opening principles
at all yeah like the the games at least
from sergey's perspective or they're not
the typical games you want to show
like newer players no no don't don't
learn
i will i will i will turn the board just
look at this position from black's
perspective
and it's hard to imagine that uh
there is such a big rating gap between
them
well he finally develops a knight move
14. but now rook g7
but okay e5 is hanging so we we could
see a trade
yeah you probably don't want to take on
g7 because e5 pawn's more valuable
so maybe knight d3
but then black cannot castle because f7
will be hanging as well
and he might even push the h pawn after
long castle well after 95 the um the
knight will defend f7
and it's also threatening a fork on on
f3
so now long castle the long castling i
like yeah because you
get the king safe you want to use the
open e file
it's another crazy crazy position yeah
the knight is defending
f7 but we of course want to trade it by
93.
oh i think i'm more nervous than nicola
well looking at his time just makes me
nervous
52 seconds yeah of course it takes a lot
of time to
because you you have so much trust in
your opponent
you really need to switch off this
feeling of uh
that that he cannot blunder that uh you
cannot outplay him you can
you just need to uh to simply play chess
and make the best moves
yeah and hopefully the first at least uh
the first few games gave him some
confidence that he can still
throw some punches and create
opportunities black
finishes development and
f2 and h for pawns not the prettiest
pawns
some trades here were probably not in
nicola's favor
yeah it was a difficult position to play
with uh a little time and
things are looking solid for uh for
black i do like bishop h3 because you
restrict the knight
it's still a little bit awkward like the
minor pieces for black are not so
impressive
but okay sergey just goes pawn grabbing
yeah that's the problem with all of
these gambits
and very aggressive lines if you catch
your opponent into
opening prep and mate it's really nice
but once you lost the
feeling of the position and you forgot
or you forgot the line or you could not
uh finish with the mating attack
you might end up just losing because the
position
and speaking of just losing uh we're
gonna see another simple puzzle rush
tactic
but it's so hard to play like blunder
free with
five seconds left yeah
yeah everything is collapsing here and
suddenly it's white king's safety is not
ideal you cannot move the rook
but is another another cool game i mean
from from an opening in early middle
game center
very exciting yeah
it was it was very very dynamic very
interesting position
but i i think we should not have played
93 because after we
exchanged the knights or to take
on d3 with a bishop maybe it was
better ah yeah because after queen the
string knight h6 i thought
and
yeah and also i wasn't sure about rook
to hg7 maybe 93 and
to keep this problem
yeah the position was uh way too dynamic
for my
ability to calculate in
bad as it is in in a
in a position that was this complex
okay that's that's on me i actually was
um
calling you to play g4 and even after
you
thought for a while i was like still
play please so it's my fault i
this blame this loss on me
it was actually a game uh
crowning against lekko and they played
g4b7 and
92 i think they played
it was famous it was famous game where
kramnik had to win
in order to win the match in versago
2004
wow all right i just have a very basic
question about this opening because
i don't play this this line for either
side but why
why do you put the bishop on d7 and not
h7
yeah yeah but then the problem is that
he goes e6 and some
some crazy position yeah yes gotcha okay
good to know yeah the funny thing is
that uh
um i played an adoption match against
wgm laura hunuk who is
actually in chat and we
we played this carol advanced aerocon
advanced bishop f5
and she played for h5 and then i
followed it with a bishop g5 line and
i ended up managing to win that game
which is
fine i i wasn't sure about g4 i know
that's uh
one that's actually the line but i
couldn't really
remember the details so i was wondering
whether it was the right decision to
get in there but this was definitely a
very interesting game and
you know i don't think i was without
chances so
anyway yeah yeah
thank you let's i'm gonna send the
rematch
okay good luck okay good luck
okay so approaching the house chances
yeah yeah no these games are
entertaining but we're kind of seeing
recurring themes of
there's being some chances but also the
um i guess a factor of time trouble and
just tactical blunders
um yeah being the big
kind of i guess uh
causes for italian have we had any
opening repeating so far no i i think i
i feel like sergey is going to play a
different opening every game
he's just trying to to find an opening
where nicola will not catch him
right but it's nice
like um i guess most grandmasters these
days
they're just so flexible and in terms of
what lines they can play and
it's hard uh of course and study so many
games
exactly i guess the exception to that is
mvl like you know
always expected night or from the
grunfeld from him yeah he even says it
himself that he's the most boring
uh like a top player
that he's always has the same the same
openings he
he's so funny
von cloud no i don't think so sergey has
a lot of respect for soviet school and
for nicola
and he will not play that yeah we should
keep in mind this is sergey karjakin and
not
hikaru nakamura so yeah
no if if a soviet player placed on king
ito he's just banished from from solid
school
and um yeah he cannot pronounce the name
anymore or or uh
even even uh mention him so nimtovich so
that yeah no this this is forbidden
yeah this opening is like the complete
opposite of a bomb cloud like players
playing very
normally ooh g4 oh wow now sergey's
turn now we will see a lesson by uh top
grad master how to
attack in joko piano yeah that's
actually pianissimo right
i don't know i've i actually don't know
the difference between piano and
pianissimo but
um i i do i really like this move g4
and i don't quite like uh black castling
because of the idea of g5 coming
exactly yeah you cannot pronounce
batwinning or very ski anymore
well we see g5 it looks really i mean g5
is so hard to stop
too
maybe we should be six now and if he
takes of course circuit probably will
not take
because then f takes e6 and f5 will open
and immediately we can see the exposed
weak
f4 square and the knight will
immediately
go to to a 4 v
or g6 oh he he plays this g5 yeah it's
it's a very very powerful attack i've
i've lost a few
like very quick games from the black
side and he's
sort of positions where now
i mean i guess sergey's oh sergey brings
a knight in
i was thinking bishop g5 was more
natural but there's so many white pieces
that that
are just having fun in this position
and the rook can always come to g1
there's each for each five ideas
uh so eric in positions like this where
white is attacking on your king what
what is normally your reaction
um i mean there is a few
positions yeah so from from a positional
standpoint sometimes you just want to
shift the focus
to the center especially if the pawn is
going for a flank attack a move like d5
you should always keep in mind
which nicola goes for another strategy
is just going for trades
so if you trade pieces and hopefully you
won't get mated
but sometimes that's hard to achieve
i like i like this move queen f3 you get
the queen involved
you reinforce e4 you're also controlling
f4 so now knight f4
doesn't make as much sense
yeah now this knight might get in
trouble after h5
we would need to find where to put it
here which knight do you take with you
could even take with a pawn
it does open this d-file but it's hard
for black to
exploit okay this one yeah well maybe
queen d7 and rook d8 but
i'm probably bringing the second knight
into play
and he also potentially can bring the
other rook once
he moves his king out of the first rank
he could join the attack there's also
like weird rook a4 or rook a5 ideas
but that's correct probably no need so
soon
but yeah there's a lot of things for uh
for black to worry about here between h5
and rook g1 yeah the knight probably
already
has to take on e4 otherwise it's so much
pressure on f6
we obviously don't want to open up the g
file completely we don't want to double
the pawns on f6
that probably already will be
strategically lost
yeah yeah i mean this is what happens
when a super grand master
follows opening principles like he
developed his pieces
and uh and yeah now
now just has a very fun attack
and queen takes e4 so now h5 is already
a thread because
uh knight is pinned to the mating square
well he's going for a counter play
against f2 sergey is immediately
replying he probably did not even
calculate it
i was wondering if h5 worked there this
interesting line
but this also seems very pleasant yep
because h5 is still
[Music]
at least still an idea and of course you
have to calculate
but the simple idea of queensland
castling
getting older we should force the queen
trade
the queen is so well centralized on e4
maybe queen c6 since the rook on each
one is not defended
oh he does it i i'm
i'm not sure whether it's good or not
that i'm calling the moves of nicola
but at least he's playing so he's not
getting needed immediately
i think there's a problem there's just a
big problem with the structure
yeah the structure definitely could have
been better
all of these phones are potential
targets
but still some success so like to get an
end game equal material
i don't know how much longer it's gonna
stay equal material
so sergey takes a nice position for the
knight on c5
nicola just ignoring ignoring the a6
pawn
though it's risky for white to take
because if white takes twice with the
rook first there's rook aid in the end
but now f3 is already a little bit
uh because already your knight is uh
finding a good square afterwards on f4
the problem with f3 is then king f2 and
the pawn is permanently
probably a weakness yeah but he could
have played the knight f4 afterwards and
the king
uh if king takes he is dropping the
knight on c5 because of discover check
yeah there's definitely some like
positional ideas to get the outpost i
wonder why sergey is not playing h5
because
uh it's better to move this knight to
like e7 right
and then you don't have any activities
yeah the knight would be very sad on e7
yeah i think we're gonna see like just
positional grind from whites
and yeah but unfortunately nicola is
getting into time trouble again
maybe rook d8 here to pin the knight to
c5 to defend the pawn it's funny knight
h8 i think makes more sense in knight e7
because the knight actually has a path
here to come to f7
and then probably especially from d6 or
h6 and g4
and then f7
his pawn structure looks solid now but
actually once the knight on c5 is gone
the spawns become
targets as well on b3 and on d3
yeah the problem is it's hard to remove
the knife from z5 because there's always
before
even if you attack it i'm just realizing
there's another idea with knight h8 to
play rook
h6 and then turn the knight to g6 and
just go after the pawn
that's very very smart very devious not
an easy idea to consider
like to put the knight in the corner and
then just return it to that now the pawn
on e5 is hanging
okay so d4 huh
interesting it's still not so easy it
does look nice for white
um nicholas holding on
time is a problem maybe rook d
because you don't want to allow these
spawns in the center if i were black i
would probably just throw in a move like
a5
just so the pawn is not a sitting duck
but at this point
you just gotta play a move and pray
[Music]
time yeah that game had a different
feel than the the previous ones
well finally
finally we saw the grand master in the
attacking seat
uh yeah i lost i lost
the sense of time it's this is already a
lost end game i presume
well it's better for me but it was still
still a game you were holding
yeah it's it's actually really nice uh
how you were defending here and finding
all this
ideas knight h8 really nice idea
was very good yeah like even rook h6 and
knight back to g6 is an idea to attack
on h4 i think i was winning with
with h5 instead of bishop e3 but i
didn't see this yeah nikola could have
played f3 at some point and put the
knight on f4
and i was surprised that uh sergey did
not push the knight earlier
but also i think uh h5 uh yeah h5
earlier i was winning the night right
because of the mate on h7
yeah i was i was worried i didn't really
want to play queen c6
which i felt was kind of a little bit of
a cop-out
but yeah actually computer considers
that the top
move uh yeah i i was still impressed
you survived like this middle game
attack i thought it was going to end
very quickly it just seemed like white
had so many resources
but it was still nice to get some some
end game
yeah all right no thank you
um it's
this is halfway point i think it's five
nothing right yeah
yeah it's five snails very good i'm
gonna mute myself a center image and
let's look at the next game okay good
luck good luck
yeah this uh this match is one of those
uh matches where you don't really
feel the time flying flying by right
it's already more than an hour into the
match and
it feels like it's just one uh really
uh intense and no
there is no time to really uh sit and uh
think that we might get tired or
anything and it's also
so fun to see to see the grand master
finally getting inspired to attack
by nicola yeah i know um i feel like
maybe it took him a few games to
remember
just basic uh sometimes who is who is
the stronger player here
he remembered wow but no it's it's a
fascinating
like this this sort of matchup is just
so fascinating to see like how
how a super gm deals with kind of um
i don't want to call nicola an amateur
player but an expert rated player
who knows his stuff but it's still um
still hard to uh to put up a fight at
least in some of these games
wow oh the original black pepper thank
you so much for three months
subscription in advance that's so nice
so thank you i do want to apologize i
didn't realize the game started but
uh we're seeing yet another different
opening yeah and at some point
uh the computer showed me that it's
called deutsche
gambit i've never heard this name before
have you
i've heard it maybe once or twice where
like people in twitch chat
want me to play it and then i just don't
know what it is
but i've seen this move order yeah
and it's i i will say it's objectively
fine for black but it's super tricky
especially for blitz yeah d4 it's kind
of a surprise move like the
yeah and history attackers
oh but now bishop f6
this is a typical puzzle puzzle rush
[Music]
as well i think it just leads to a trait
of material
it's complicated though yeah but then
you take on e5
and f7 is hanging yeah f7 is hanging
right
well i mean our queen we have to take
the bishop first
but you do open up the f file i mean
there's yeah there's a few different
captures to to consider
so you're saying bishop takes f6 yeah
bishop takes f6
bishop takes f1 is forced uh dj 1 here
is forced
bishop d8 rook d8 rook g1 and there's
even knight c2
in the end yeah knight 2 1
knight c3 knight a1
aha okay so he's going into something
you have to take it's two pieces for a
rook right
um yeah i guess that's true yeah after
you take on d1
you're gonna take the knight eventually
on a1
and you usually i prefer the two pieces
over the rook in these sort of
situations but black's gonna have
black still has all eight pawns
i mean it's fantastic position
i'm wondering why he didn't take on f4
maybe knight b5 was
with some idea probably knight b5 is
annoying attacking c7 and a7
but now it takes if 4 is already
a good move we should note um
so white has knight and bishop for rook
and two pawns
yeah but he's not taking on the third
pawn which looks free like g5 ideas
i wonder what he was worried about he
just wants to activate the rooks
you know what after after he takes that
f4 there was rook f1 and if g5 there's
g3
pressure and if g5 g3
okay so some complications that sergey
wants to avoid
it does look pretty balanced right now
yeah no definitely um i mean
usually two minor pieces are are worth
the rook and duponts
because they they they can coordinate
better together
of course it depends what uh kind of
position it is what stage of the game
of course in an end game two pieces
become extremely powerful
always have to keep in mind like uh
black creating past pawns
uh but what about white pushing b pawn
to break this pawn structure and create
potentially
uh oops sorry an outpost on d5
oh you mean like b4 b5 yeah i think the
the issue is black can just kind of
ignore it
and bring that to an open file yeah i
mean it's definitely an idea
it's kind of this uh this endgame
minority attack
yeah and these sort of positions when
you have minor pieces
one strategy is to create like some weak
squares
for your pieces like you really want to
create a d5 outpost
but it's not easy to achieve and it
probably takes a lot of time
well maybe to start with he couldn't
move the knight to e3
because it doesn't really do anything on
a3 while
black until the pawns all
all of the black bones are still in
places right so which means
both rooks are not working so
white can just improve the position of
the pieces
i feel like i i feel like nicola should
have just played
a quick move there like he okay he plays
king f2 which also looks fine
but there is no reason he took a minute
and 22 seconds there
as type of position you should either
play knight c2 or king f2
quickly and save time at least in my
opinion
thank you so much the original black
pepper for all the gifted subs
thank you oh yeah thanks thanks sorry
guys it will be a lot of mowing now
in my channel yeah there's been there's
been a lot of support today
um i know across all the channels so
very appreciative i will move this uh
alert box over my face instead of nikola
because
it's it's a bit disrespectful
i have to cover up some face let's move
f5
yeah so he he is really eager to open up
but what does it
mean so his threat was to take on e4
which i think he can still do
yeah but if f takes c4 and he cannot
take
yeah another
another tactics and now black's going to
get um
now d5 and this this is uh this is very
far from
equal unfortunately
it's it's a very fun position to play
for black because you just keep like
building up the center
eventually becomes
monstrous and white just cannot do
anything here
yeah i mean you would love to like as
white you would love to have a pawn on
d4
f4 to reinforce e5 but
yeah if you had an f4 it would be still
probably much better but black can
simply put
a6 then c5
d4 and it's almost unstoppable
yeah no it's hard to like create a
stable blockade here for whites um
okay we should know king d4 would would
defend the pawn but
wouldn't last so long yeah you don't
want to have the king there
so what nicola is trying to do with this
b4 move he's trying to
delay the advance of the pawn c5
um but i i think at some point we're
going to see yeah put the
knight to g4 it's kind of a
blocker but of course until b6 c5 or a5
giving up the pawn and then we'll push
c5 d4
and it's and it even comes with a tempo
d4
check and then d3
no it's it's such a such a difficult
position to play
it does look like a wall of a minister
of defense true
we have comments in charge yeah as
correctly chess.com tweet said today the
minister of defense
cannot cannot adopt by only defending
you have to win
all of the 10 games uh and this is an
adoption attempt by
the blitz and rapid world champion and
the
challenger of 2016 sergey koreakin
against
nicola stoicin so nicola only needs
half a point at any game and then he
wins
the match yeah the pawn's just too
powerful there yeah
this unfortunately
probably the night if the knight was on
e3 it would
have been better
i'm probably better after f5 yes yeah
well my palm palms are getting very
strong
yeah f5 was a nice move
i felt like maybe bringing the knight to
c2 and then to e3 would have been one of
the
ways to improve the position
moved the knight and and also i think
that knight c3 was
more natural instead of knight a3
somehow
to get the knight to the center
i have a couple of full disclosures here
i actually
had this part of the part of the opening
prep
and i actually studied this whole line
with bishop g4
with my friend and coach international
master alex estany lopez
and here is a small problem i couldn't
remember how the line goes
after bishop g4 and i actually i'm glad
that i remembered how it goes but i
remember
him warning me that this end game is
supposed to be equal but
it may be tough to prove it in practice
and that's basically what happened
um i needed to get the knight knight in
place sooner i
don't think uh you know i'm looking here
at the computer evaluations and
king f3 was basically where it's all
started going south
yeah according to the engine so yeah
which
actually makes sense and you know then
after f5
i didn't you know i saw f5 but they
fought and then
f e5 was just a blunder
yeah so okay
very good uh okay
thank you thank you sergey uh
let's see let's play one more game
actually there's four more left thank
you
all right now okay
we're gonna see no it's it's not the
queen's gambit
are we gonna see how london yeah
i'm so happy oh i'm so happy
i was expecting the king's indian but it
also did not happen
everyone is like oh please please d4 is
such an exciting move
so nicola if i remember correctly has
beaten me in the king's indian
um when i i didn't play london but this
this is um
they're actually going into like a a
very topical
london line um
yeah this is one of like the most
critical variations of the london
i can hear how excited i am i'm so
excited right now
yeah because this is this is still all
prep at least for me
um so what do you do here with the queen
you so there's there's a few
um the main line is queen c3
and queen a2 is incredibly risky could
result in
in black b5 is the main line right
against it
so there's some bishop e5 ideas uh-huh
uh queen a3 i'll admit i
i don't know too much about it's
probably the third most played move
but in general the um the play for white
involves this this pin
combined with pawn c4 and knight d4 and
95
and this is going to be a game where um
sergey might be down material like after
queen takes e5 whites down a pawn
but there's gonna be a lot of
compensation this is one of my favorite
lines to play
so as black you have to be very well
prepared and it doesn't seem like nicola
is in his preparation anymore he is
probably
is but he's trying to remember it's so
difficult to
keep keep all these lines in mind but
like we already had
uh the marshall the adams attack
we had different lines in italian
for both sides they switched colors
um so and nicola is not a professionally
playing player
so it's not his job to
play chess that's a very good point yeah
to
have so many different openings to try
and keep track of
of course it helps to play all of these
adoption matches every sunday basically
today is only one exception where he he
has
two adoption matches uh within three
days
uh so he's kind of still in shape right
because of
playing all of these games and plus
working with elizabeth pets and with
astani
but still but as he noted like even if
you study
like these specific lines before um you
still have to remember them in the
moment
which is not always easy to do yeah and
i've had many cases myself where like
i'll go into a line that i studied like
years ago
and then it's hard to uh to come up with
everything on the spot
i'm a little bit surprised sergey is
just kind of slow playing with castling
i thought it's more typical for white to
be aggressive
with c4 95 but
okay some time to figure out what to do
for black
so now black still can play either e6
or queen takes c5 i assume that
any other move will be too slow you need
to castle
as soon as possible so it's either e6 or
queen c5
of course a6 did waste one of the tempos
for for the development so now
so as as black here you you kind of have
to be a little bit worried of knight b3
which defends the c5 pawn and also
covers a5 square
leaves the queen very precarious
so this move attacks the bishop but it
violates two opening principles
he's moving away from the center and
he's moving the same piece twice
without his without most of his pieces
developed
i mean even even white can
just ignore it potentially and
do something active like c4 for example
yeah c4 it's um it's interesting
seven also taking away a5 square from
the queen
and now this knight also can get uh
under attack
by knight t5 for d4 for example the
knight will
uh will be hanging while the knight
would attack
c6 so this move
really was against this type of opening
yeah i mean it seemed like nicola he
just wanted to trade material like trade
like for bishop
but created some additional problems for
himself
okay bishop g4 makes sense
trying to diffuse the diagonal pin the
knight
i like smash time fools comment that
nicholas hat is there to cover up
nicolas large brains so that sergey does
not get intimidated
i think intimidation already already was
successful after move
after game two that was already enough
of uh
he can take it off
[Laughter]
but yeah this um this this queen's
position is of course quite um worrisome
oh he does play c4
so now the king's safety becomes a big
issue plus
uh the c6 will be
we should note that c4 also opens up
this kind of d1 a4 diagonal for the
the white queen so if ever queen takes
e5 there's queen eight four ideas
yeah now queen c5 probably already will
be losing
he plays e6 trying to take one c5 with
the bishop and then
castle if he manages that then black is
okay
but of course now everything comes with
a tempo
uh if queen c5 he can even play queen b1
attacking b8 and queen b1 is a nice idea
there's also a tactic here of queen a4
then rook b8 will win the queen
but i also like queen b1 because it
comes with the tempo while
freeing the knight on f3 and so his
knight can
join like knight e5 or knight
d4 it's so many ideas and then the
second knight even can come
so as black here do you dare take on a2
i guess not no
no a2 is long gone you had this chance
on
move uh six
seven move seven taking it now would be
admitting that you did something wrong
but sir sergey plays your move right
away queen b1 that's
a very nice find because you're
threatening rook b8 you're threatening
to move the knight to various places
yeah oh rook b7
oh rook b7 this bishop is so nice on c7
yeah and then
this bishop will be what do you do even
here
the queen has to you already but if you
move the queen then rook b8 and it's
basically
it's a mate it's a queen d8 mate
afterwards
yeah no time resigning with 0.7 seconds
left
that's that's a skill
yeah this is why you don't mess with the
london yeah i think
i think that a6 wasn't so good
in the opening because it's losing of
time
a6 uh
yeah i think eric is very happy because
we
i i was so thrilled i was waiting for a
long time he was so excited
once d4 happened he was like oh it's
london it's london
[Laughter]
um
yeah i think after castle you should not
have played knight h5 because knight is
completely out of yeah okay
yeah no i am i don't i'm actually
i don't have a zen of this particular
position in this particular line
um so i i remember actually playing a
game against
uh elizabeth pecks and ana music
and uh i got crushed in that there too
so i think it's time for me to
refresh my london thing i didn't i
didn't expect we would be playing london
today to be quite frank with you so
maybe
maybe i can i should watch some of
eric's videos on youtube again
so well it's a type of line like you you
have to be very very well prepared
i think for black to go into yeah yeah
yeah
so it's it's very concrete yeah i'm
pretty sure that
queen a3 is actually okay
right it's just
probably not the main line so i think
queen c3 is the main line these days
yes and then there's some idea where you
leave the queen on c3 you play e6 and
bishop e7
you just develop quickly yeah
yeah okay all right well leave and learn
there you go right
upset i'll send the rematch thanks you
sergey okay
good luck good luck thanks okay
so this is game eight
yeah that's so much to learn so many
beautiful openings
yeah it's nice they've been mixing uh
mixing things up i think that
that game was the quickest game uh so
far
that's how badly can london go go for
you if you don't
know the principle most people think
it's just like a solid boring opening
but uh there's room for for fun
okay yet another so we've seen a
sicilian but we haven't seen this
variation
um just a classical well i could play a
rouser here
with bishop g5
and nicola going for f3 also a solid
move
that's classical as well
so i'll admit this is an opening again i
don't really
know too much theory but um i know it is
topical
among uh high-level players
in classical sicilian it maybe it's one
tier below like nightworf
and svashnikov in terms of just
theoretical standing but um
okay we're gonna see a fun position pawn
d5
oh there is some trolling in nicholas
channel now saying that
london is a solid boring unambitious
opening system
oh wow provoking the commentator
yeah it's uh always a challenge to
manage all the trolling and
um and chatter but yeah thanks again
original black pepper
for for all the bits yeah the original
black pepper
thank you for also gifting 25 11.
that was really nice of you thank you
i look away for a moment queen's right
and then queens are gone
just a more peaceful i think after that
last game nicola just wants a more
peaceful
uh solid game where he's just to calm
down and
to have it under control he's playing
wide
he's position is uh
i i actually like uh i like his position
slightly more but of course e5
uh is a better center for for black
but the question is what do you think it
seems relatively balanced i mean black's
gonna have a little bit more space
and question how you complete
development for white
maybe bishop d3 you can still get away
with
yeah bishop d3 or bishop b5 maybe
provoke a4 a6 which will be
a weak weakening of b6 square
with both players have a pair of bishops
both have a knight
so that's this is like the strongest uh
combination of the bishop player and the
light piece
so moving the pawns for no reason here
can result in some
really bad consequences
yeah i was going to point out that black
sometimes has the idea of playing a6 and
b5
to then later play b4 um
so it might be a useful move at some
point
but he probably wants to prepare it
again
sergey doesn't need to hurry up here he
can just wait and see
what white will play yeah king c7 is a
very patient move
but you are giving my time to put the
rook on on e1 and then
white's completing development i see i
see why we had this
some server issues it's a title tuesday
and of course it's the first time nicola
is playing adoption match during the
title tuesday that's why
server is acting a little bit so it's
all nikola's fault for um
for just overloading the server with
this match
yeah there's probably many many people
to blame
i mean the number like just uh the
number of active users
on chat stock has been skyrocketing last
several weeks um servers have to keep up
yeah so this is another position like if
i were white i would play rookie one
probably within a few seconds yeah in
positions like this
if you see a good move don't look for a
better one
i think it's better to save time for uh
for the end game for for the moment
where you need to calculate where
there is that this time will be really
precious and
of course having two minutes advantage
for sergey is already
quite a lot yeah and if there's any like
big takeaways from this match of course
there there's opening preparation
there's these tactical moments
but i think a big thing for nicola to
improve on is just time management
and recognizing the critical moments and
and spending less time
in the moments that aren't so critical
yeah and that's something that not too
many people
like specifically work on but yeah
rational
time usage is one of the topics which is
widely ignored
in the literature because of course end
games are always a weakness
many players
probably underestimate how important end
games are because they don't happen
all the time but of course if your end
game
is quite weak then you might even try
subconsciously
try to avoid getting into an end game
which
uh of course leads you to getting
worse middle game which can can also
result
yeah yeah it is but time management is
uh
it also of course relates to
psychological issues which uh
can be just being not um
not confident enough or playing with a
stronger opponent
and always double checking everything
overthinking
so here a lot of a lot of problems can
can come up but with all that said i
mean
okay nicolas still has enough time i
mean it looks like things are gonna
trade down a bit like he could force
rooks off the board
yeah he can trade the rooks he can also
consider maybe
pushing f4 to block the
to block the center well black probably
doesn't want to capture an f4 because it
gives
more play to the bishop but if you push
your pawn you block your own
bishop on e6 f4 is kind of double-edged
move it does give black the option of e4
getting a defended pass pawn
but of course you have a knight you can
always move the knight to
to block it on e3
okay i like bishop d3 just keeping calm
i
i don't like g5 now g5
makes f4 already impossible or you would
have to play g3 to play f4
and then black can play f4 or
d4 oh sorry e4
oh you mean g4 from white uh no g5
if blacklight
maybe it's not so and then g4 yeah and
to get more
space but even just the move g5 itself
already makes you
feel really uncomfortable now h5 h5 is
gaining more space preventing white from
ever
maybe even considering g4 and g4 was it
was kind of a positional idea that if
black takes with f pawn
you get this very nice e4 square for a
minor piece
but that's not likely going to be
irrelevant
maybe f4 now is is even
better because we also gain g5 square
black will never be able to play g5
after knight f3
if black does not push the pawn if black
pushes the pawn then of course d4
becomes available
for the knight okay so nicola trying to
stir up something on the queen side
um i did like the move a4 and b4 seems
double edge like you're you're trying to
create it's a bit risky
also your king becomes really weak now
i i mean i know they said we don't have
queens on the board but
look at the king yeah and also the apon
like you want to play okay one here yeah
yeah a pawn needs to be defended but if
you defend it with rook a1 it's
e4 so these two bishops now start
playing
and they feel the blood
and now f4 is probably too late yeah i
know
this whole i guess the whole queenside
play is just backfired for white
like nicola wanted to create weaknesses
in black's territory but just created
weaknesses in his own territory
of course taking on h5 makes absolutely
no sense because this pawns will simply
run and you cannot stop it
that's why he did not want to to play a
four i also can understand this two
bishops become super powerful
yeah it was a solid position just
combination of i guess time pressure and
creating some weaknesses yeah before
wasn't good
yeah b4 was just you know not enough
time to
figure out what to do in this in this
position i think it was
the position should be equal yeah
maybe four immediately was
yeah i think 840 was actually
fine it's just b4 was
[Music]
anyway okay oh well
uh uh thank you warren crowder greatly
appreciated
okay so all right
um i
played this i played this line before
and
i think uh you know the position was
fine and then
it's just you know as soon as i played
b4
yeah sorry i think that that
in the opening if white wants to play
for advantage
uh white should play queen e2 instead of
queen e2
uh it was actually my game against
wesley saw
so nine more okay i'll check it out
thank you
so the nine queen e2 as opposed to okay
we get the end game which is drawish
okay well you know i don't mind the draw
against you for obvious reasons but
okay it's hard to do
all right very good let's send the
rematch thank you
yeah we don't mind the draw uh
between nicola and sergey well it is
interesting to see when they have like
josh
positions and then to see how sergey
creates
chances to win um sometimes
it's just about being patient like using
the time advantage and waiting for that
time advantage is very important in this
of course
okay so another new opening b3
nicola going i i've seen a lot of people
do this where they they try and just
diffuse the diagonal
so triple fiancado
maybe we will have the other one b6 as
well so you have to be careful that
would be
six yeah there's some discoveries maybe
it's playable
but at this point it's probably is but
still
uh it's probably not necessary to to
risk like that
uh but yeah about how uh sergey
is uh using the time advantage and some
creating
you only need two weaknesses in order to
win right uh
as we all know from in some cases you're
losing one weakness
in some in some cases but two is
definitely enough so
you can probably call it like a balance
wheel where uh
he just tries to shake the position from
both sides
until something cracks and he starts
putting pressure
on that one weakness and then another
and that's what it he did by moving the
rook like rook
uh from h8 to a8
no it's very instructive because when
you think about like a strong grand
master
playing a weaker player you think that
they're just gonna like overpower them
like attack and then find tactics but
there's also the notion of just playing
like patient strategic chess
and um and yeah just being
being a bit more slow and methodical and
waiting for the opportunities
there's a lot of spam in nicholas
channel
even i joined oh hahaha
yeah i guess when one person spams it's
not okay but then when everyone spams
it's completely fine right also if
commentators
start spamming this is definitely okay
yeah then um
yeah i guess we set the example for
people
biased commentator i mean it's hard to
not to be
we all support nikola of course
he does such a great preparation he
works so much on his chest he improved
so much
and yeah this is like a culminate
culmination of uh
getting adopted by sergey
of course this experience is either way
priceless no yeah no it's incredible
like um
i mean just uh not only like a life
experience
but uh but also just invaluable learning
experience
like not every day you get to play a
world i think
sergey is in like the world top 20 still
um
because you learn so much from from
these games
yeah i feel like just a simple play
and he just crushes you whatever
whatever you do whatever he does he
crushes
you he blunders he still crushes you
it's it's just
insane so i was going to say i feel like
this game is
the least theoretical opening of
everything we've seen so far
like every game we've it feels like
we've heard the players quote some like
famous game
in recent times but now it's just kind
of just
okay natural development from both sides
a b5 is a kind of fancy move
yeah i like b5 it does put
that this this bones b5 and c5
they're kind of called hanging pawns and
uh they they can become a weakness but
can also become
a strengths of the black's position sure
and then just to clarify hinging pawns
it doesn't mean that they're necessarily
completely undefended and attacked it
just means that they're next to each
other
and there's no pawns on the adjacent
files so no pawns on the d
or it's like an isolated pair of pawns
yeah and sometimes it's a strength
because they control space but it can
also be a weakness
if you ever advance one of the pawns you
leave the other one backwards
so but for now it seems like they're
well reinforced i like this move queen
b6
you defend the knight and also want to
bring the rook to d8 after developing
the bishop bishop maybe goes to a five
nature really
i'm not sure like between f5 there's g4
there's b7 b7 is also
a good position oh there's e6 yes e6
we did not expect that but that would
have been my first bearing
c4 c4 is actually a logical
idea like just try and create a pass
pawn and then maybe bring the rook to c8
and of course here white cannot be too
careless because
if white thinks okay i'll take they'll
take
attack the bishop i play rook b1 but
then ah
bishop f5 and here you will lose some
material
can you repeat that one more time what
if black
plays c4 for example and white decides
to take
thinking okay now black will attack the
bishop
that's alexa
yeah i was just thinking saying that if
black pushes it
starring
alexa quiet quiet
i didn't think i said her name but she's
always listening
sorry for that she's always listening
big brother is watching you it's a
problem sometimes
literally
okay a few things just happened there um
but the knights have come to g5 and g4
and now
black has lost this bishop in getting
some ugly structure
yeah the problem is that the bishop on
e6 had a nice idea in mind
but it was too slow he had no time to
push c4
which would come with uh an attack on b3
because bishop would be attacking b3
through the pawn as well
but he simply did not have this uh
didn't have the tempo
yeah sometimes when you put your bishop
on e6 you also want a pawn on h6
to just prevent knight g5
but yeah here i really like this move
from sergey knight e4 this does so many
things
it defends f2 it attacks c5
by unleashing the queen also offers a
trade of bishops
and the knight is like can't really be
removed from e4
as blacks pawns are feeling of course if
white if white wants to take on c5 they
would have to trade the bishop first
that's what he does and if he takes on
c5 he has to be careful with
knight f or rook f2 maybe is better and
then you can bring the other room
but he's still going for it uh but also
knight
d7 comes you know what he's threatening
uh queen c3 also knight g7 yeah so
there's there's all these forks all over
the place
like so many black pieces are targets
you have really no time to take on f2
yeah this is probably he overlooked this
idea of queen c3
yeah i don't even know how you defend
both i guess
okay take on f2 and hope for the best
and now sergey can decide between queen
c3 or knight d7
oh triple fork maybe incoming
oh painful combined with the pin
there's a term i like to use when you
pin and you fork
it's called a pork
it's a very powerful tactic a very
delicious tactic
unless you're of certain religion yeah i
guess that's true yeah or
just vegetarian or vegan
which can also be called a religion yeah
but he goes for rook d7 so not even
porking but rather just going for the e7
pawn
that's a monster threat because then
you're going to win f6 yeah
and now he can take on d5 because when
you're up material
also trading pieces is uh
is always helpful useful but also he's
taking only seven afterwards and the
position collapses after
rookie seven he also comes rookie one
with another fork
not the pork this time just the four
just that's just a pin sorry
because the the the rook on f6 is uh not
defendable well now it is defended by
the queen
but okay 97 still coming
oh 97 painful
every single black piece is attacked
here
you would love to teleport this queen to
h5 mm-hmm if only and maybe
yeah if the if the queen could be on h5
that would be nice
instructive game though i like the play
from uh from sergey
waiting for that bishop g4 instead of
instead of knight g4 and black was fine
i think 15 uh yes
just not to give up this bishop
yeah i was hoping to have a counter play
already
on the f file didn't materialize so
okay yeah yeah but it's very risky
positionally
yeah opens up too much no
okay well here you go guys
um you know you if you don't lose the
tactically you're gonna use positionally
what can you do
anyway it's fine that's expected all
right last game
one more try i did defeat to adoption
adoptions in the very last game so i'm
very hopeful
all right yeah going all out thank you
yeah we can expect even more spamming in
the chat now
don't overdo it guys don't do it for the
spamming do it for supporting
so what opening the original black
pepper thank you for
5 000 beads to nicola
thank you for the support black pepper
yeah i always have to monitor nicholas
chat too
wow i just have that's it goes insane
okay i abandoned my moderation duties
for today hope there's at least one
one person who's still there who's a man
yeah but they they already resigned as
well
i saw a hedgehog uh just conceding to
do this yeah sometimes you just can't
stop it
no you cannot stop this yet another
sicilian variation this time sicilian
khan
i'm slightly disappointed we're not
seeing like any really really crazy
dubious gambits but maybe that's
expected between these two players
yeah it's hard to expect it from sergey
because he already
found himself in a couple of quite
uncertain positions to put it mildly
especially the second one
so going into a gambit line which he is
not familiar with
well would be even more risky for him
i feel like this opening is just the
opposite of a gambit like super solid
for both sides
i think sergey is probably going to
employ a hedgehog
which i know is uh so d6 also will will
be played
and then g6 and h6 right that's uh
um you don't always have to include
these king side pawn moves but the
hedgehog is usually defined by having
at least the a b and d and e pawns on
the sixth rank
and it's nice like you control the
squares on the fifth rank
there's a good number of people who like
who consistently ask me in the twitch
chat to play a hedgehog
it's a nice uh sort of adorable animal
or maybe i i actually transposed this to
a
hippo hippo is oh the hippo is yeah
easy to get the animals confused
yeah especially in my channel i
so i have guess flower to give nikola
power i love
that anna maya sets a train trend
let's do it i've never had such a spam
in my own channel i'm joining in
i feel like the strategy is just just
copy and paste
yes it is very simple that's why it's
called
five head strategy
i joined in once i don't i usually don't
partake in space oh my god it's probably
the first time ever eric participates in
this
so what do you think is the idea of
nicola
here after a four is he gonna continue
with f5
oh b4 i guess the question is
he's doing a hedgehog in the center but
a large a more active
larger hedgehog because he's on the
floor yeah that's that's like really
powerful hedgehog very angry hedgehog i
would say
so angry hedgehog versus just quiet
peaceful hedgehog
is he gonna play g4 h4 a4
and control all the fourth rank
ah you know what it is it's not hedgehog
it's
i i um porcupine
porcupine oh porcupine is it's i think a
related animal
it is it is a much uh it's a scarier
yeah it is a scary hedgehog type
porcupine
yeah and i feel do porcupines do they
shoot out their spite like they
if you're if you're too close to them
they can shoot you with their spikes i
think
that might be a myth i don't know but
you don't mess up
i immediately remember the pokemon
there was a pokemon with the same
abilities
but they probably also do the same no i
don't remember my pokemons
i would probably yeah imagine maybe
there's some similar one
anyway um nikola okay first improving
the bishop
it's logical
but g5 might actually be like a a plan
here
g4 even wow ooh
the spam has crept into my chat as well
i think i got it
yeah spam this baby to help nicola
maybe that the chat is becoming very
creative yeah
it it happens
i'm waiting for my mods oh there is the
screws
over the first mode who joined the trend
something going south if and then once
then there's some people who are like
just joining the stream and they're
seeing the chat and they're they're just
asking like what's happening today
and what is happening this is the last
game of an adoption attempt by
sergey kariken who is
doesn't need to be introduced but we can
do it again he is
uh the world blitz champion the world
rapid champion
the vice world champion
uh in classical chess of 2016 played
magnus carlsen
and was leading in the match
until the game 11. he was very close to
being world champion
yeah yeah he was also better in that
game but then
collapsed under pressure and magnus but
will he collapse under pressure in this
match it's game 10
he needs to win to win the match yes
but there is a 1 000 rating point
differential between them
at least according to chess.com yes
according to chess.com it's
1000 if um
if we take feed level uh nikola does not
have
a feeder rating but if we convert his
chest.com rating into feeder then it
becomes
800 roughly so what are the odds
the odds uh mathematically
mathematically before the match
the odds were almost four percent chance
for nicola to avoid that option wait
that's not bad
that's like four that's four and a
hundred that's 125.
yes so it's worth one in 400 to draw
and one in 800 to win
yeah but after nine games of course this
lowered but not by much
it actually does not really have much of
the change
after each game because the chance is so
small
but we only need one draw
that's correct and he has a very like
stable like solid position like
in some sense his pawns are kind of
targets
but they also control space or they are
well defended
and this is a bit peculiar what sergey
just did
and yeah you you saw that he played h5
which means sergey was afraid of
g4 happening and now that h5 will become
a potentially a weakness
which white can play against already
nicola can play
queenie too and he really needs to hurry
up yeah it's not too often you see h5
followed by
castling pretty cold blooded
but now nikola is maybe a bit perplexed
and
taking taking a little bit too much time
yeah we need to probably the easiest
way to continue he can also play knight
eight four
attack b6 it goes for knight e2
92 unleashes uh the d file also the
diagonal for the bishop
but he's going to have to be six yeah
he will have to play very fast now
that's another position like probably
had to play some quicker moves
like sometimes you just play quick moves
like king h1 h3
knight g4 is a bit annoying thanks
come on play and this this
clock is giving me exactly so so nervous
oh which key could just get two minutes
more
we need to like find a chess.com if
you're a chess.com admin you can like
manually add time
if they're friends sergey can add time
from to him but i don't think they added
each other
we need to oh no
that was such a promising game yeah that
was a cool cool opening position
but time i guess time was the culprit
yeah you just freeze
i know that feeling
congratulations sergey yeah
congratulations successful adoption
you uh for the record uh this is my 22nd
adoption match
and i've lost only three against you
against grandmaster amber hamilton
and against the grandmaster and the
music sergey i think you're me
you're still muted
yeah yeah yes yes thank you i was i was
saying that
thank you and it was it was very
impressive that
uh you played so well and
now i actually uh truly told i
i had a online phone stream
class with dania about how to play this
marathi bind positions uh the problem is
that
i was completely out of the prep out
about
you know move after i play queen d3
on ninth move the only thing i really
didn't
know what to play against b6 and bishop
b7
and the only thing i remembered was what
dania told me was that
in this position you're supposed to play
f4 and b4
uh anyway it was well i think that in
this line
uh after b6 white normally plays bishop
with three bishops on f3
and then roxy one and ah gotcha
yeah something like
yeah we were kind of at least i was kind
of hoping to see like g4 h4a4 and just
throw all the pawns
but i was afraid of this yet yeah we we
noticed that with h5
wow okay i i was a little bit curious
about the the combination of h5 and
castling king's side
yeah is this is this just a typical idea
or
no actually actually my move h5 was more
like prophylactic
against g4 because i didn't want to
castle immediately because of the g4
and so i played h5 and then when you did
castle you weren't concerned about h5
being a target well i i don't know i
i felt like i would have time for the
control play maybe on
c4 palm or e4 palm
some sort fair enough okay
yeah but the petition is of course very
unclear i mean if white plays pre
precisely it might be slightly better
for white maybe engage one
instead of an idea to to have bishop
giovanna's on
g4 or
so sergey after after 10 games and 10
wins do you have any
any takeaways or any advice you would
give nikola for
i guess further improvement well
nikola is very good in the openings it's
just completely clear
he might play sometimes more
positionally
like i mean for example not to to
to to exchange the bishop on the sixth
to to
to double the pawn i mean just to play
some positional moves and
you you you don't have to be creative
all the time but
he's playing quite well
so thank you so much i'm sure he would
he would win next time
oh thank you that's very kind of you
that's very greatly appreciated i think
look uh you know objectively i had a
four percent chance to avoid the
lose getting adopted um
i actually definitely had chances the
best chance i think was the very first
game and there were a couple of end
games that were objectively drawn
the problem with playing this game 10
position
is uh i didn't have
i didn't have the plan in other words i
didn't know
after i got the position i wanted around
you know with f4b
for bishop e3 and the rook ac one
after after which i think i'm close to
being better
if not better i didn't know how to
proceed and
obviously in a blitz game you don't have
time and against especially against
somebody
like sergey so yeah you were completely
fine
i mean is that
even in the final position if you don't
play f5 you can play knight ce2
and it's very complicated position yeah
now f5 yeah f5 was a desperation move
you know you know basically lost
position or
a lot they didn't have time so yeah
yeah yes that is what i actually wanted
to tell you that you should not spend so
much time
because you are in time trouble many
times
fair enough all right well thank you
sergey that's very greatly appreciated
uh sergey was kind enough to uh
interrupt his preparations from the
super final of the championship of
russia which starts this weekend
i i'm gonna root for sergey and let's
hope nepo doesn't hear me
thank you very much don't clip this guys
please
uh i'm very much looking forward to
to the super final and i'm looking
forward to sergey come
making many more appearances on twitch
and playing many more matches
which we're going to do our best to
happen we can
i think which community twitch chess
community can only benefit from
uh having as strong players as sergey
as its part which was up to all the
point of this match to be
very frank with guys uh you guys i
i had more chances that one can hope for
uh so thank you sergey again that's very
greatly appreciated
good luck with the super final